pleasure such a pleasure so earlier this  year it was a hard year for me you know  i even have like i choose life you know  but um i listen to your stuff and you  know you help me through it so  what's your name john john i'm really  glad we're together me too man can i  write something i'd love that  listen to me when i'm writing here is  the biggest truth in the world it's just  deciding what to look at it's just like  tilting your head and turning around and  looking at it differently and you have  the strength to do that every day  thank you man you're welcome  make sure you look at that when you need  it  you just have to look at something that  is good there's always something that's  good too i wish  [Music]